okay guys Mary here at e3 2016 and I'm
here with Jacob from system era
Softworks how's it going hey not too bad
now I actually fell in love with this
game from a trailer several months ago
this is Astra NIR and I'm so excited to
see it today right yeah this is this is
a live bill of the game that we just
kind of brought with us today three and
it's the early game experience so you
start off on a planet and you have
nothing and you have to build up so
excited let's actually jump right in the
trailer is actually really motivating if
you guys haven't seen it you should
check it out but it's so exciting how
much you guys packed in how much
creativity into this game I mean
basically this is like the world is your
oyster right now and you are running
around surviving and exploring yeah
that's right so as you can see we
started with a spaceship here and we're
gonna try to build up exhale through the
full progression tree we're gonna try to
build up to a vehicle and to get some
fuel so we can launch off and go explore
some other planets as well and so you
actually can manipulate the world with
your little tool there is really
fascinating and I don't even want to
know the tech that goes behind being
able to manipulate the world in the way
that you do but you're basically
obtaining resources with your little
suction gun there yeah that's right it's
the same same tool that you used to pick
up the resources you can completely
deform the terrain with so you can go
the planets are fully spherical and you
can go around and shape them into any
shape that you want those cultures build
roads build anything yeah and now how do
you know how you are I mean I've saw in
the trailer at least that you can not
make it you can you can croak is that
the case yeah so we are a survival game
over a third person survival game so
that what that means is we can show a
lot of the stuff that's happening to the
player directly through animations and
sound and just and things in the
backpack so we have this UI interface
here where you can just see the amount
of power that you have directly on on
your backpack rather than having to have
some UI elements which is great there's
almost no text on that is that on
purpose that your game is kind of more
globally able to be played absolutely
yeah seeing things in the world is great
for new players as well because they you
can show 3d objects that they're already
familiar with and
have a paradigm that is much more
accessible to new players especially now
so how much time do you have before you
feel like you are in danger or like I
mean you should feel free to explore
without like getting yourself into too
much trouble here yeah so what we
actually do is we start people out on an
easier planet and so if they want to
they can just kind of dig around and
have the kind of open more creative
experience here but then we have the
best rewards on the more dangerous
planets and so once you travel to a new
planet that's when you kind of get
thrust with more of the difficulties now
what kinds of dangers will these players
be experiencing are there actually
life-forms on these planets there's a
plant life that's hazardous you'll come
across things that you kind of have to
use problem-solving to figure out how to
get past and there's a lot of just
environmental dangers I mean space is
dangerous without having to have you
know weird aliens like shooting at you
I've heard space is a dangerous place to
be just surviving alone you know not
even mentioning alien plant life that
kills you what tells the player that
they're in danger there's something
wrong well hopefully we indicate that
just through good physical mechanics and
so when there's when there's a planet
coming at you it's you have to figure
out what's what's actually happening and
reacts with what you've been given or
what you've built even so we're already
in a night cycle right now how long is
your day in night cycle and does that
change based on the planet I mean so
that plants plants rotate at some speed
and it's actually very based on planet
and from the Sun and a variety of things
yeah so it just depends on the actual
mechanics of the orbits and all that
stuff just naturally yeah well every
players start on the same planet
no it's they're all procedural worlds so
we will procedurally generates solar
systems that each and each a new player
will start I have no map no star map
that they have to navigate through it's
all just what they get it generated per
player per story or are there seeds
yeah there are seas but the seeds are
hidden so you just jump into a game you
get your own new unique world maybe will
happen so you can save off that seeds
you can come back to it later or you can
send it to a friend Baek ho look at this
awesome new universe that I discovered
yeah you probably get this a lot but
there's definitely like a no man's sky
vibe from that for how endless and how
much you guys can basically explore so
this is something where the players
should feel really inclined
you play die play play again try another
world and continuously explore in
various ways yeah yeah no max guy really
really hit home with the idea that
there's this whole universe out there
that you have no idea what's there and
so I think that's that's a theme that we
can all hit on and I think that works
well for both of us but there's a little
bit more of a technical aspect to this
or you know you're actually building
items right now to survive which is
really new and unique and really fun to
kind of give it more of a scientific
vibe so what are you making right now
yes so like on that point like there's
lots of sci-fi games which kind of have
sort of an alien influence or it's sort
of like it's more fictional aspect but
we like to think of ourselves as an
aerospace game answer an aerospace
fiction game and so we try to look
around everything in an interesting
aerospace reality I mean there's lots of
companies there's NASA there's there's
spacex doing real things and we try to
like mimic some of that and give people
mechanics that they can play and like
live out the aerospace experience how
realistic would you say you're trying to
be with us as much as it until it runs
up against game design and then you can
have to scale back and still have it be
fun we're trying to make it accessible
but how scientific can you make it
before it's no longer fun a certain
extent I think if you're clever you can
find ways to merge the two but but we
want people get people the experience of
airspace without necessarily all of the
gritty details what happens when you
build yourself a whole can you like
actually build yourself a whole we can't
climb out of can you make mistakes like
that you can if you run out of power
deep underground your deform tool will
work slower so it'll take a longer time
to get up there but we never want to
completely overly punish people people
should always be able to like use simple
problem-solving to get it out of
situations and in if nothing else you'll
respond and you can try again and so
here actually I'm gonna build on my
first ever vehicle so I took a lot of
resources I had to go around and get a
lot of this compound this compound
resource here and this would be the
first ever vehicle that's the player
will craft in the game
um it sounds like you are utilizing your
time and resources properly and you can
probably make mistakes build the wrong
things make wrong choices and try again
yeah you can yeah so so here I've got
this solar panel that I was using just
power the base but I can actually pick
it up and put it on the rover here and
depending on what the situation is if it
was nighttime that would be completely
useless but but luckily it's a day cycle
right now and you're gonna ride around
exactly so so as I'm going here there's
charge up normally once it's night this
will run out of power and then if I
offer stranded nowhere that's my fault
and I should have planned better yeah
damn so you're actually taking huge
risks with your life even when you're
just exploring like that yeah that's
right we want people to learn learn how
to plan for the adventures that they're
going on so what are you doing with your
car then like where are you planning on
going also I'm like I feel like I'm in
watching the Martian right now because
you're like going off on this really
dangerous adventure yeah so I've been at
the Martian there's this really great
quote that uh that Mark Watney says he
says when you're out in the middle of
nowhere or I'm gonna get a completely
wrong but you solve one problem then you
solve another problem and if you solve
enough problems you get to go home and I
think that's such a great thing for us
as well also that you're going to
science the [ __ ] out of a bunch of
things [ __ ] out of everything and and
hopefully like it's a little bit further
future than the Martian setting is set
in so we can take a few more liberties
and give so you have your you have your
card and you're able to be way more
mobile now but where are you going so
it's actually I need some more with this
resource up here and so this is a rich
slightly rare resource than the compound
resource so often you'll have to go
further for these kinds of resources
just depending on the kind of reward it
gets you so I've come up here I can
gather a lot of this and actually remain
powered because I'm a tethered into my
rover here so I'll gather a few of these
which I'll need to build a actually fuel
your Sun just went down it did yeah
close to the base here because I've been
planning it that all along almost yeah I
think you got this all figured out right
like nothing's gonna go wrong yeah I
hope so I mean if it does go wrong we
hope that players can kind of share
creative solutions to different problems
together we want that we would like to
have the kind of community that would be
seems a definitely like a community
driven type thing where you're going to
see forums where people are going to
cross check their issues and see what
other solutions other people have found
we're also a co-op game so a co-op is
huge for us so I mean if you if you
haven't figured something out you can
just team up with a friend and they can
show you directly and with it being
third person that's just another
astronauts running around in the world
with you and he can literally directly
show you how to do something and this is
online co-op play yeah so just through
your through your Steam friends list you
can just join up with anybody
immediately join progress all that
that's incredible actually so now you
have a condenser going on here what are
you doing now yeah so the condenser
takes a whole bunch of electricity to
work and it'll only work on plants to
have the correct atmosphere so on this
I'm this easier planet there's a good
atmosphere and it can draw water vapor
from the air and condense it down some
sort of science a [ __ ] science is
happening yeah exactly into a hydrogen
based fuel and then I can use that
hydrogen based fuel to put into my
rocket and we can go to other worlds I
want to go to another world let's go to
space a space is infinite there's a lot
of worlds that go to it's not actually
it's not how big is it it's it's
finitely massive I actually don't know
the number of what we think how many
planets and solar systems are out there
but I mean it's like billions of
trillions could a player basically play
in one seed for a really really long
time and never find everything so on
earth access we're just shipping with
solar systems but we kind of have this
bigger aspiration that yeah you can
break outside of your solar system and
maybe the surrounding solutions like
these stars that you see up in the sky
here are actually like other other
systems that you can go go visit they
have people on them and it moves like
some sort of matchmaking service when
you travel to that that slower system to
it and then you can play locally
yeah I'll be really rad you're looking
for is this your meter right here that's
indicating your fuel yeah a little bit
fuel here enough to at least uh blast
off and we can blast off no oh my god
that actually happened really fast all
those stars are still there so they're
in the exact same spot so that's not
just art assets showing your sky those
are actual stars that you can travel to
yeah absolutely and actually the Sun
here is not just part of the sky box
it's actually a 3d object in the scene
so all these planets are orbiting
orbiting the Sun here and this moon is
actually orbiting orbiting my planet
here and so I'm actually going to travel
to this is a travel animation your are
you actually driving I'm not driving no
it all just uh pilots automatically it
figures out the trajectories and brings
you there and I say that's that's part
of people asked us that question a lot
about like how can I build this
spaceship and fly it manually and we'll
definitely have that eventually but like
I said we want to give people the
experience straight out of the box also
there's a lot of things that can kill
you already let alone flying so maybe
just traveling to the ships and
surviving there is pretty good at least
at the start exactly it's satisfying
enough to build up to even just get a
rocket ship going to go to this planet
always I think it's here we go you guys
are in early access so this is still an
ongoing process how big is your team
we're only six people so early access is
great for us because like if there is a
lot of stuff that we're gonna polish up
even after we continue to release like
we're committed to working on this game
continuously until it's the best
possible version of the game it can be
did you find a cave yeah I didn't even
know this was here actually there's
people in the cave you can't just go in
caves willy-nilly
I mean there's there's mystery down here
I think I think though uh
I'll leave the mystery of this cave to
two players when they come and play it
and we can and we can just end the demo
right here how about that incredible so
it looks like there's just so much to
discover where can people find out more
about this game so go to astronaut space
it's a that's that's our URL and there's
links to our Twitter there our Facebook
you can get a newsletter there and our
steam page like a huge mix of everything
you love from no man's sky to
Kerbal to the Martian
it's all here and there's endless story
I mean oh you died oh my god
that's so sad well you're at the start
again you're you more chances and this
looks like just something that you can
sink hours and hours of time into and
play again so I'm really stoked to see
this game thank you so much for showing
me Jacob I think we hope everyone had
really enjoys it when it comes out all
right sweet so you guys can find out
more about that that was Astra near and
for everything else games you're gonna
want to stay tuned to games but